The following content is
provided under a Create
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality education
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's get
started then.
We went through Rayleigh
fading very, very
quickly last time.
I want to spend a little more
time on it today since it's
one of the sort of classical
models of wireless channels.
And it's good to understand
how it works.
And it's good to also understand
what all the
assumptions that are made when
one assumes Rayleigh fading,
because they're really
quite a few of them.
OK, so what we're doing is we're
assuming flat fading.
In other words when we talk
about flat fading, we're
talking about fading where if
you generate a discrete model
for the channel, that discrete
model is just going to have
one path in it.
In other words, the output is
going to look like a faded
version of the input.
It'll be shifted in phase
because of the unknown phase
in the channel.
It'll be attenuated by
some random amount.
But if you look at the waveform,
it'll look like the
waveform that you transmitted
except for the noise.
And that's what really is
represented by this one tap
model that we've been
looking at.
In general we've said that you
can model a pretty arbitrary
channel for purposes of
somewhat narrow band
communication by using a
sequence of taps where usually
for want of something better to
do, we model those taps as
being Gaussian random variables,
complex Gaussian
random variables with zero mean,
and variables which are
circularly symmetric.
And we assume for not any very
good reason, that the taps are
independent of each other.
I mean we have to make some
assumptions or we can't start
to make any progress on trying
to analyze these channels.
But we should realize that all
of these assumptions are
subject to a certain
amount of question.
OK.
When we assume a single tap
model, and these tap models
are always given with the number
of the tap given first,
and the time given second.
So what we're assuming here
is the only tap is
the tap at time 0.
And it's at time 0 because we're
assuming the receiver
timing is locked at transmitter
timing.
And we're just going to get
rid of the zero because
there's only one tap, and
call this G sub m.
We're also going to pretty much
assume that G sub m stays
relatively constant
for a relatively
long amount of time.
Except as far as this analysis
of Rayleigh fading goes, we
don't have to assume that.
Because in fact, when we're
assuming Rayleigh fading, the
analysis that we're going to
follow, the receiver doesn't
know anything about the channel
at all, except that
it's a single tap model.
And therefore what the receiver
does is it goes
through maximum likelihood
detection assuming that that
single tap is just a complex
Gaussian random variable.
OK when you have a complex
Gaussian random variable as
you've seen in the problem sets
and we've noted a number
of times, the energy in that
complex Gaussian random
variable is exponential.
And the magnitude is just a
square root of the magnitude
squared, namely the energy.
And that has a Rayleigh
distribution which looks like
this, namely the probability
density of how much
response you get.
We'll base this law here.
And the phase of course, is
equally likely to be anything.
Namely the phase is uniform
and random.
This density looks like this.
I wanted to draw this so it
would emphasize the fact that
the magnitude is in fact,
always nonnegative.
But also to emphasize the fact
there's a whole lot of
probability down here
where there's
very, very little channel.
And this is in fact what gives
rise to the fact that if you
try to communicate over Rayleigh
fading, and you don't
make any use of diversity--
and we'll talk later about
diversity--
in fact you can't communicate
very well at all.
And that's because of this very
bad region here where the
channel is very badly faded.
You send a bit on this channel
which is very badly faded, and
there's nothing much the
receiver can do.
And that's the thing we
want to try to get a
real feeling for.
OK so the output of the channel
when you put in an
input U sub m, and we'll think
of this as being a binary
digit for this time being.
So the output is going to be
the input times this tap
variable, which is this complex
Gaussian random
variable plus a noise random
variable, which we're also
assuming is complex Gaussian
and circularly symmetric.
OK so what we have, if you're
going to make two hypotheses
about two possible values of
U sub m, look at what this
random phase does here.
No matter what U sub m you
transmit in one epoch of time,
the channel is going to rotate
this around by a completely
random phase.
It's going to add a noise to
it which has a completely
random phase.
And the output is going
to come out.
And the output has a completely
random phase.
Namely the phase of the output
cannot possibly tell you
anything about what
input you're
putting into the channel.
OK so in other words, in this
model that we're using, the
phase is completely useless.
And if we want to talk about
anything connected to using
likelihoods, the only thing we
can use is the magnitude of
the output.
OK.
Now, why don't we just analyze
it in terms of the magnitude
of the output?
Well when you analyze these
problems, Gaussian things are
usually much easier to analyze
than things like this.
Not always, I mean we
have to get used to
analyzing all of them.
But this particular problem of
Rayleigh fading is really
easier to analyze in
terms of these
Gaussian random variables.
But it's easier to understand
in terms of recognizing that
the only thing you can make any
use is these magnitudes.
OK if we only use one complex
degree of freedom in a signal,
namely if we try to send some
signal and we only use one
input to the channel, then
we only get one output.
Namely we sent U sub
0, we get V sub 0.
And we try to decide from
V sub 0 what was sent.
We're really in a very bad
pickle at that point.
Because the only thing that
makes any sense, since we can
only use the magnitudes, is to
send a very small magnitude or
a positive magnitude.
Magnitudes are positive
anyway.
So if you're going to send
binary signals, this is your
only choice-- if it
makes any sense--
if you make this larger
than zero you're
just wasting energy.
So you only have this choice.
And you can choose the amplitude
a that you're using.
But that's the only thing
that you can do.
OK, this is a very nasty thing
to analyze for one thing.
It gives you a very large error
probability for another thing.
Nobody uses it for
another thing.
And therefore almost all systems
of trying to transmit
in this kind of Rayleigh fading,
always use at least
two sample values.
In other words, instead of
just putting one complex
degree of freedom into the
channel, you're going to put
two complex degrees of freedom
into the channel.
And the thing that we're going
to analyze, because it's the
easiest thing to do in this
discrete time model we've
developed, is to think of
modeling hypothesis 0 as
sending two symbols U sub 0 and
U sub 1 will make U sub 0
equal to a, and U sub
1 equal to 0.
And the alternative case, if
we're going to try to send
input 1, this is binary
transmission.
You can talk about more than
binary transmission, but
binary is awful enough.
You get U sub 0 and U sub
1 is equal to 0 and a.
So what you're going to
be doing here in this
pulse-position modulation, is
choosing one of these two
different epochs to
put the data in.
So in one case, you put all your
energy in the first one.
In the other case, you put all
your energy in the second one.
Mathematically, this is
completely equivalent to
frequency-shift keying, that's
phase-shift keying.
And if we had a little
more time, we
could talk about that.
And I'll probably put an
appendix in which talks about
those two systems.
But in fact, it's completely
the same thing.
It's just that you're using
different complex degrees of
freedom than we're using here.
So we're really analyzing
FSK and PSK.
And that's where people usually
come up with these
analyses of Rayleigh fading.
OK when we have input 0, what
we receive then, is the 0 is
going to be the input a, times
the magnitude of the channel
of time 0, plus a
noise variable.
The noise is complex
Gaussian, remember.
The second input is just going
to be the noise variable.
Alternatively, if we're sending
the second symbol,
which means we put our energy
into the second degree of
freedom, it means that what
we're going to get is the 0
was just going to
be the noise.
And the second output
is going to be the
signal plus the noise.
And remember, both this variable
and this variable are
both complex Gaussian.
The phase doesn't
mean anything.
So what we can use is simply
the magnitude.
OK, so when we have hypothesis
equal to 0, what comes out is
going to be, the 0 is going
to be a complex
Gaussian random variable.
Let me introduce a new piece
of notation now.
Because it gets to be a real
mess to constantly talk about
a Gaussian complex random
variable, and talk about it's
real part and imaginary part as
being independent Gaussian.
So I'll just call this
normal complex.
And this first thing is the
mean, which is a real and
imaginary part, but it's
zero in most of the
things we deal with.
And the second one is the mean
square value of this random
variable V sub zero.
So this quantity here is now
twice the variance of the real
part of V sub 0, and twice
the imaginary part of
the variance of v0.
We scaled the noise in
a peculiar way here.
And I apologize for all
of the mess that
occurs when we do this.
Because sometimes we think of
the noise as having variance N
sub 0 over 2 in each real and
imaginary degree of freedom.
And therefore N sub 0 in a
complex degree of freedom.
And sometimes we think of it as
having variance N sub 0 W
Where does that difference
come from?
It's this infernal problem of
the sampling theorem being so
critical in most of the models
that we talk about.
OK because when you use the
sampling theorem, the sinc x
over x waveforms that we use are
not orthonormal, they're
orthogonal.
And this factor of W appears
exactly because of that.
They appear because the
magnitude of the signal is a,
and the energy and
the power in the
signal is then a-squared.
OK.
In this case the power in the
signal is not quite a-squared
because we only send energy in
one or the other of alternate
degrees of freedom.
So therefore, if we look at a
time one second, we get W
complex degrees of
freedom to use.
We only send energy in half of
those so that the actual power
that we're sending is a-squared
divided by 2.
OK.
Because of that, when we
normalize the noise the same
way the signal is normalized,
we get this
variance W N sub 0.
If you're confused by that,
everyone is confused by it.
Everyone I know, when they go
through calculations like
this, they always start out
with some arbitrary fudge
factor like this.
And after they get all done,
they think it through or more
likely they look it up in a book
to see what somebody else
has gotten.
And then they sweat about it a
little bit, and they finally
decide what it ought to be.
And that's just the way it is.
It's the problem of having both
the sampling theorem and
orthonormal waveforms
sitting around.
It's also the problem of
multiplying the power by 2 as
soon as we go to passband.
Because both of those things
together generate all of this
difficulty.
But anyway, this is
the way it is.
And the important thing for us
is that what we can have now
is under these two hypotheses.
We just have two Gaussian random
variables, complex
Gaussian random variables.
And in one case, the larger mean
square value is in one.
And in the other case the
larger mean square
value is in the other.
OK.
So just reviewing that.
If H is equal to zero, V sub 0
and V sub 1 are these complex
Gaussian random variables.
If H is equal to one, then we
have this set of Gaussian
random variables.
The probability density of V
sub 0 and V sub 1, and now
it's more convenient to use the
real and imaginary parts
for the Gaussian density.
Anytime you're working problems
of this type, try
both densities using real and
imaginary parts, and using
magnitude in phase, and see
which one is easier.
Here it turns out that the
easiest thing is just to use
the ordinary conventional
density over real and
imaginary parts.
And what we wind up with is
this Gaussian density.
On V sub 0 the density is V sub
0 squared divided by the
variance a-squared
plus W N sub 0.
And on V sub 1, it's this
Gaussian density V sub 1
squared divided by W N sub 0.
Just because here we
have this variance.
Here we have this variance.
OK, on the alternative
hypothesis when H is equal to
one, you have the same thing
but the denominators are
switched around.
When you take the likelihood
ratio, you want to take the
ratio of this, to the
ratio of this.
If you look at it and you take
the logarithm of that, you're
taking the ratio of
this to this.
Incidentally the coefficient
here, you could write it out
if you want to.
It's 1 over the square root of
blah, times 1 over the square
root of blah.
But if you recognize that the
coefficient here has to be the
same as the coefficient
here, you don't have
to worry about it.
So when you take the log
likelihood ratio, you get this
divided by this.
You have the same form
in both cases.
In one case, you have this term
minus this term and this
term minus this term.
And the other case well, for
V sub 0, you have this term
minus this term.
And for V sub 1 you have this
term minus this term.
Because of the symmetry between
the two, this just
comes out to V sub 0 squared
minus V sub 1
squared times a-squared.
And when you do the algebra, the
denominator is a-squared
plus W N sub 0 times
W N sub 0.
OK.
What do we do for making a
maximum likelihood decision?
Maximum likelihood is map when
the threshold is equal to 1,
which is when the logarithm
of the correct
threshold is equal 0.
Which says that you take this
quantity, and if it's
nonnegative, you choose
H equals zero.
And if it's negative, you
choose H equals one.
Which says you compare V sub 0
squared and V sub 1 squared.
And whichever one is larger,
that's the one you choose.
And if you go back and look at
the problem, it's pretty
obvious that that's what
you want to do anyway.
I mean you'd be very, very
surprised when you're
comparing two Gaussian random
variables where one of them
has a larger variance
than the other.
And on the other hypothesis,
the absolon
has the larger variance.
If you came up with any rule
other than to take the
magnitude squares and to then
compare those two magnitude
squares, you would go back and
look at the problem again
realizing you must have
done something wrong.
But anyway when you deal with
problems like this, I advise
you to take log likelihood
ratio anyway.
Because every once in awhile you
find something which comes
out in a somewhat
peculiar way.
But anyway, here there's
nothing peculiar.
So what we have to do
now is to find the
probability of error.
Now what's the probability
of error?
OK if we actually transmit zero,
then V sub 0 squared is
exponential.
It's exponential
with this mean.
Namely this is the mean
of V sub 0 squared.
And V sub 1 is exponential
with this mean.
In other words, this is
a big exponential.
And this is a little
exponential.
The two of them have probability
densities that
look like this.
This is not going to work.
The big one has a probability
density that looks like this.
And the little one--
this is big--
and the little one has
a probability density
that looks like this.
And what you want to do is to
subtract a random variable
with this density from a random
variable with this density.
So you're convolving two
exponential densities with
each other.
And unfortunately, you're taking
the differences of two.
So you're convolving the
negatives of this with this.
And then you have to integrate
the thing.
And it's just something
you have to do.
And the answer is, the
probability of error is then 2
plus a-squared over W N
sub 0 to the minus 1.
OK that is really
an awful result.
Because that says that if you
increase the energy that
you're using, the probability of
error goes down very, very,
very slowly.
And if you look at this picture
you think about it a
little bit, it should be clear
that that's the only thing
that can happen.
OK.
Because if you increase
a-squared a little bit, it's
not going to save
you much here.
Because when you have a bigger
a-squared, it's just going to
move down the value
of g bar that's
going to give you trouble.
Namely when you double a, the
value of magnitude of g that
gives you trouble just goes
down by a factor of two.
When that goes down by a factor
two, this bad part of
the curve just goes down
in a quadratic way.
Well that's what this
is telling us.
OK.
I mean the thing that we see
is a quadratic and a.
So we're sort of assured that
we're doing the right thing.
And we're sort of also assured
that the reason why this
result is so awful, is just that
sometimes the fading is
so bad there's nothing
you can do about it.
OK now the signal power
as we said before is
a-squared over 2.
Since half the inputs
are zero.
So we can put twice as
much energy into the
ones that are non-zero.
And therefore when you put this
in terms of the average
signal energy that you're
sending, what we get is E sub
b over N sub 0.
OK.
So that again says exactly the
same thing that this does.
It's worthwhile keeping both
of these notions around,
because we have done something
kind of peculiar here.
I should mention it for you.
As soon as you're looking at a
fading channel, the power that
you're talking about becomes
a little peculiar.
Because remember when
we were looking
at white noise channels?
What we were looking at is the
power at the receiver, the
signal power as received
at the receiver.
Now at this point, we still want
to talk about E sub b.
We still want to isolate this
problem from the attenuation
that occurs just because of
distance and things like.
Because of that, when we model
g, this original model that we
use here was a model in
which the magnitude
of g had mean one.
And we made it have mean
one so that the energy
would come out right.
Which is another reason why you
get confused with these E
sub b over N sub 0 terms.
OK so anyway, that's
the answer.
And E sub b is in terms of the
received energy using the
average value of fading.
OK we next want to look at
non-coherent detection.
Non-coherent detection
is another thing that
communication engineers
use all the time, talk
about all the time.
And you have to understand what
the difference is between
coherent transmission and
incoherent transmission.
The general idea is that when
you're doing incoherent
detection, you're assuming that
you don't know what the
phase of the channel is.
And somehow you want to do your
detection without knowing
that phase.
The difference between Rayleigh
fading on this kind
of channel and incoherent
detection, is that with
incoherent detection the
receiver is assumed to know
what the magnitude of the
channel is, but not the phase.
It's harder to measure the phase
of the channel than it
is the measure of
the magnitude.
Because the phase changes
very, very fast.
If you look at these equations
we have for what the response
of the channel is, you see the
phase changing many, many
times during the time where the
amplitude of the fading
changes by just a little bit.
So a very common assumption that
people make when trying
to do detection is that
it's incoherent.
Partly, people get used to
analyzing incoherent
communication.
And I've seen this
so many times.
And they insist on building
communication systems using
incoherent detection.
They will swear up and down
there's no way you
can measure the phase.
And what they're really saying
is that's the only kind of
communication they understand.
And because that's the only
thing they understand, they
become very, very upset if
anyone suggests that you ought
to try to measure the phase.
But that's a tale
for another day.
OK so now we want to look at the
case where we're assuming
that we know the magnitude
of the channel.
It's just some quantity that
we'll call g tilde.
We're assuming that the same
magnitude occurs both on U sub
0 and U sub 1.
We're going to use the same
transmission system that we
used before, namely
pulse-position modulation.
We'll either put our energy in
U sub 0 or we'll put our
energy in U sub 1.
We'll try to detect
what's going on.
But we just give the detector
this little extra amount of
ability of knowing what
the channel is.
I'm going to talk more later
about how you can use this
knowledge of what the channel
is, and how you can measure
what the channel is.
But for now we just assume
that we know it.
So the phase is random
and independent
of everything else.
So under hypothesis H equals
zero, we have the output of
the channel.
And times 0 is whatever input
level we put in a, times what
the channel does to us, times
e to this random phase.
And V sub 1 it's just--
plus Z sub 0.
And in the other case we have
V sub 1 equals Z sub 1.
And under the other hypothesis
V sub 1 is this input with a
random phase but a known
magnitude and again, a
Gaussian random variable.
Phases are independent
of the hypothesis.
The phases are independent
of the
magnitudes which are known.
The phases are independent of
everything and therefore, we
just want to forget
about them.
So the question is, how do we
make a maximum likelihood
decision on this problem?
Well you look at the problem.
And for the same reason as
before you say, it's obvious
how to make a maximum likelihood
decision just from
all the symmetry
that you have.
If the magnitude of V sub 0 is
bigger than the magnitude of V
sub 1, V sub 0 corresponds to
this little bit of extra
energy that you have.
So if V sub 0, the magnitude
of V sub 0 is positive, is
bigger than the magnitude
of V sub 1, you want to
choose H equals 0.
And alternatively you'll want
to choose H equals 1.
It's obvious right?
I've tried for years to find
a way to prove that.
And the only way I can prove
it is by going into Bessel
functions which is the way that
everybody else proves it.
And this seems like absolute
foolishness to me.
And if any of you can find a
way to do this, I would be
delighted to hear it.
I will be in great admiration
of you.
Because I'm sure there has
to be an easy way to
look at this problem.
And I just can't find it.
OK anyway, we're not going to
worry about all these Bessel
functions, because that's just
arithmetic in a sense.
So we're just going to say well
it can be proven using
all of this machinery.
So what we really want to find
is what is the probability of
error when we make
that decision.
And when we make that decision,
namely what we're
looking for is the probability
of this magnitude then, is
bigger than this magnitude
when H equals one is the
correct hypothesis.
Because that's the probability
of error then.
So you have these two
different terms.
You just go through all of the
junk that's in the appendix to
the notes we passed
out last time.
If you want to go through that,
I think it's great.
It's an interesting analysis.
Certainly not going
to do it now.
When you get done doing that you
find out the probability
of error is exactly one half
times e to the minus a-squared
times this known magnitude
of the channel.
I mean, a-squared and g tilde
have to appear together here.
OK because what's coming out of
the channel, the magnitude
of what's coming out of the
channel without noise is just
a times g tilde.
They both come together
everywhere.
And therefore, they have to come
together anytime you're
talking about optimal detection,
probability of
error, or anything else.
So these two appear together.
We have the same noise term down
here as we had before.
Because again we're using a
sampling theorem analysis and
the noise in each of these
random variables is W N sub 0.
OK so that's a little surprising
that that's what
the noise is.
If you knew the phase also, if
the detector knew both the
magnitude and the phase of the
channel, it would be the
conventional Gaussian
problem that we've
analyzed many times before.
And the solution would be that
probability of error is equal
to Q of a-squared times
g tilde squared
divided by W N sub 0.
Now if you remember the
estimates we've come up with
and the bounds we've come up
with on the Q function, the
simplest bound that we came
up with was this.
Namely you take this thing, you
take one half of it, which
is the Gaussian density
with the coefficient.
You multiply it by one half.
So this is the simplest estimate
we can get of this.
On the other hand when this
quantity is large, a much
better estimate of this is to
have that estimate which has a
1 over the square root of pi
times W N sub 0 over a-squared
g tilde squared in it.
So we have that term extra.
Which says that when this
is large, whenever we're
communicating at all reasonably,
this probability
of error is much smaller than
this probability of error.
However you talk to any
communication engineer, and
they'll say when you have a
good signal noise ratio,
incoherent detection
is virtually as
good as coherent detection.
And why did they say that?
Well it's because the
probability of error goes down
so quickly with energy here.
It's going down as a square
of an exponent.
Well it's going down as an
exponent in the energy.
The question you want to ask is
how much extra energy do I
have to use?
If I'm using coherent detection,
how much more
energy does an incoherent
detector need at the input in
order to get the same results?
And then you see the question
is very different.
Because if I increase this
quantity just a little bit,
this probability of error
goes down like a bat.
OK.
So what happens then, when you
compare these two terms is
that as the signal to noise
ratio gets larger and larger,
the amount of extra energy you
need to make incoherent
detection work as well as
coherent detection goes down
with 1 over a-squared.
Which says that these
communication engineers who
swear that they like incoherent
detection in fact,
have something on their side.
because they don't
have to assume so
much about the channel.
They have something which
is more robust.
And in fact what's turning out
here, is that even though this
error probability is a little
bigger than this error
probability, there's only a
very negligible amount of
extra dB required to make
the two the same.
So it only costs a little bit of
extra energy to be able to
use incoherent detection instead
of coherent detection.
OK so this is very
strange now.
We have a nice error probability
which is almost as
good as the Gaussian
error probability
using incoherent detection.
This is assuming that the
channel, that the receiver
knows what g tilde is.
But now we go back and think
about this, and look at our
detection rule, which is the
optimal detection rule.
And the optimal detection rule
is no matter what g tilde
happens to be, we compare the
magnitude of V sub 0 with the
magnitude of V sub 1.
In other words, we have analyzed
this assuming that we
know what g tilde is.
We know what the gain
of the channel is.
But the receiver doesn't pay
any attention to it.
OK so now we have this very
peculiar situation where
incoherent detection with a
known value channel is almost
as good as coherent
detection is.
But at the same time Rayleigh
fading gives this awful error
probability.
So now you have the final part
of the argument take this
probability of error, multiply
it by the probability density
of g tilde squared, integrate
it to find out what the
average error probability is
when we average over the
channel fading.
And guess what answer you get?
Well you ought to be able to
guess it if you've looked at
the homework already.
Because in the homework you
actually go through this
integration.
And bingo you get the Rayleigh
fading result.
Which says that the problem with
Rayleigh fading is not
any lack of knowledge
about the channel.
Knowing what the channel is
would not give you, even
knowing what the phase is of the
channel would not give you
a lot of extra help.
The only help in knowing what
the phase is, is to get this
result instead of this result.
And even that won't
help you much.
The problem is anytime you're
dealing with Rayleigh fading,
the channel has faded so badly
a large fraction of the time,
that you can't get
an acceptable
probability of error.
OK so now we have to
stop and think.
What do you do about this?
Well you have two general kinds
of techniques to use at
this point.
OK and one of them is to
try to measure the
channel at the receiver.
You take the measurement of the
You send it to the
transmitter.
And the transmitter then does
something to compensate for
the amount of fading.
One thing that the transmitter
can do is anytime the channel
is badly faded, it increases
the amount of
power that it's sending.
That's what typical
voice systems do.
And the other thing that you can
do is change the rate at
which you're transmitting.
You can do all sorts of things
with the transmitter if you
know what the channel is.
You can respond to it
in various ways.
And all these different
communication systems have
various ways of dealing
with that.
And we'll talk a little about
that on Wednesday when we talk
about CDMA.
The other thing you can do
about it is use something
called diversity.
And the idea of diversity is
that instead of sending this
one bit, trying to use as few
degrees of freedom as
possible, you try to send your
bits using as many degrees of
freedom as possible.
If you can use a large number of
degrees of freedom, and if
the fading is independent on
these different degrees of
freedom, then in fact
you gain something.
Because instead of having one
random variable which can
totally cripple you, you have
lots of random variables.
And if any one of them is
good, you get through.
So you get a benefit
out of diversity.
OK so that's our next topic.
Namely, how do you measure
the channel?
Because if you're going to use
diversity it's a help to know
the channel.
If you're going to use coding,
coding is just another way to
get diversity.
Again your coding will work
better if you know what the
channel is.
So somehow we would like to be
able to measure the channel
and send it back to the
transmitter if we want to
alter the power, the rate of
the transmitter, and to let
the receiver use it if the
receiver is going to.
Well we have seen that when
you use one bit on just a
couple of degrees of freedom,
knowing what the channel is
does not do you much help.
If you use coding or if you use
one bit and spread it over
a large number of degrees of
freedom, then knowing what the
channel is gives you
a great deal.
This is one of the basic
confusions that everyone has
when they deal with
Rayleigh fading.
Because when you look at a
Rayleigh faded channel, the
first thing you analyze is this
incredibly small number
of degrees of freedom.
And you say wow, that's awful.
There's no way to
deal with that.
And then you start looking
for something.
And you say, well diversity
helps me.
But in general, this is the
general scheme of things that
we're going to use.
OK.
So as we said channel
measurement helps if diversity
is available.
Why does that help when
diversity is available?
OK, think of sending
this one bit.
You get one reception, and then
you get another reception.
And on this reception, you
get one amount of fading.
On this reception you get
another amount of fading.
If I don't know how much fading
there is it doesn't
help me an awful lot.
It helps me some.
But if I know that this channel
is faded badly and
this channel is not faded, then
I'm going to use what
comes out here instead of
what comes out here.
And then my detector is going
to work much, much better.
When you look at diversity
results, always ask yourself a
couple of questions.
Is the detector using knowledge
of what the strength
of the channel is on these
two diversity outputs?
Is the transmitter using it's
knowledge of what those
channels are?
You get very different results
for diversity depending on the
answers to both of
those questions.
OK, so if you have a multi-tap
model for a channel--
OK remember the multi-tap models
that we came up with.
We we're looking at transmission
using multipath.
And we had multipath in
different ranges of a delay.
We came up with a model which
gave us multiple taps for a
discrete model of the channel.
You get a large number of taps
if you're using broadband
communication.
Because using broadband
communication 1 over W becomes
very small.
And therefore these ranges of
delay become very small.
And if you're using very narrow
band communication,
that's when you have
the flat fading.
Namely flat fading is not flat
fading, it's fading which is
flat over the bandwidth
that you're using.
So if you use a broader
bandwidth and you have
multiple taps, then these taps
are going to be independent of
each other.
And you automatically
have diversity.
So the question is how
do you use that.
Well if you're going to use
it, you better be able to
measure it.
OK so now we're going to try to
figure out how to do that
measurement.
And the first thing to do is
to assume the simplest
possible thing.
I mean, suppose you know how
many taps the channel has.
Suppose it has k sub
0 channel taps.
So the channel looks like
this, G sub 0, G sub
1, and G sub 2.
You're transmitting a
sequence of inputs.
OK remember all of this stuff
came from trying to model a
channel in terms of discrete
inputs, where you're sending
one input each one
over W seconds.
So you put in a sequence
of inputs.
You have these three different
channel taps here.
And what comes out when you put
in a single bit here or a
single symbol.
You get something out when
this tap right away.
You get something out here
one time unit later.
You get something out here,
one epoch still later.
So all of these outputs
get added up.
And therefore the output here
at time m, is the input at
time m times this tap, plus the
input at time m minus 1
times this tap, plus the
input at time m minus
2 times this tap.
Because it takes these inputs
that long to go through there.
All this is is just digital
convolution, OK.
I'm just drawing it out in
the figure so you see
what's going on.
Because otherwise you tend to
think everything happens at
one instant of time.
Then we're adding this
white Gaussian noise.
When we're talking about
digital systems, white
Gaussian noise just means that
each of these random variables
are independent at each
other random variable.
They all have the
same variance.
And the real parts and
imaginary parts
have the same variance.
And they're independent
of each other.
Namely these are all normal
random variables.
Since we're sending a, or minus
a, or something with
magnitude a, we want to divide
by a out here, if we want to
figure out anything about
what these taps are.
OK so suppose that what we send
now is a bunch of zeros,
followed by a single input,
followed by a bunch of zeros.
What comes out?
Well the thing that comes out is
at the point that this big
input comes in, we get a
G sub 0 out at the time
that you put in a.
I mean we're leaving out
propagation delay here.
We got a times G sub
1, the next epoch.
Then we get a times G sub
2, the next epoch.
And by that time the input is
completely out of the filter.
And we get zeros after that.
So if you put in a bunch of
zeros and then a single a, you
got a nice measurement
of the channel.
There's Gaussian noise added
to each of these inputs.
But in fact you do
get a reading of
each channel output.
When you divide these by the a
here, then you get something
which is a measurement of the
appropriate tap G plus
Gaussian noise on it.
OK now you try to make an
estimation from this.
And the trouble is we don't
want to say much about
estimation theory.
But in fact the notes gives you
a very brief introduction
into estimation.
There are two well-known
kinds of estimation.
One of them is maximum
likelihood estimation.
And the other one is minimum
mean square error estimation.
Maximum likelihood estimation is
in fact exactly the same as
maximum likelihood detection.
Namely you look at the
likelihoods which is the
probabilities of the outputs
given the inputs.
And what's the input
in this problem?
The input is these channel
variables.
Because that's the thing we're
trying to measure in this
measurement problem.
We assume that the probing
signal is known.
It's just a bunch of zeros,
followed by a, followed by a
bunch of zeros.
So we know that.
We're trying to estimate
these things.
So these are the variables that
we're trying to estimate.
So we try to find the
probability density of the
output conditional on the
knowledge of G sub 0.
Which is just the Gaussian
density shifted to
a times G sub 0.
You then look at the maximum
likelihood estimate of G. So
you're looking at the value
you can put in to maximize
this estimate which comes out
here as a times G sub 2.
And then at this appropriate
time, you're looking at G sub
2 here, plus a noise
random variable.
And since the noise is zero
mean, this quantity here is in
fact the best estimate in
terms of the maximum
likelihood that you can get.
If you assume that this is a
Gaussian random variable and
this is a Gaussian random
variable, you can solve a
minimum mean square error
estimation problem.
It's much like the map problem
except these random variables
are all continuous here.
But it's a little different from
the map problem in the
sense that you can't have
equally likely inputs where
you have a continuous
random variable.
You make them all equally
probable.
The only possible value
you can have is zero.
Because it has to
extend forever.
So anyway, maximum likelihood
detection is just normalize
what you get so that in the
absence of Gaussian noise, you
would get the variable
you're looking for.
And then ignore the
Gaussian noise,
and that's your estimate.
OK.
If you want to do this and you
want to use the strategy, it
looks like a very
nice strategy.
But what's the problem in it?
If this sequence is somewhat
longer, you need a whole lot
of zeros in between each
probing signal.
And what that means is you're
going to be using your energy
and clumping it all up
into the small number
of degrees of freedom.
Which means you're going to be
sending a lot of energy at one
instant of time and then nothing
for a long period of
time, then a very big signal for
awhile then nothing for a
long period of time,
and so forth.
If you do that, the FTC
is really going
to be down on you.
Because you're not supposed to
send too much energy in any
small amount of time or any
small amount of frequency.
So you're supposed to spread
things out a little bit.
You say OK, that doesn't
work too well.
What am I going to do?
How can I choose a sequence of
input so they have relatively
constant amplitude, but at the
same time so that when I go
through this kind of filter, I
can sort out what's coming
from here, and what's coming
from here, and
what's coming from here.
Well it turns out that the
answer to that question is to
use a pseudonoise sequence.
And the next thing I want to
do is to give you some idea
about why these pseudonoise
sequences work.
OK so we'll think in terms
of vectors now.
OK so we have a vector input, u
sub 1, u sub 2, up to u sub
n, a vector of length n.
So we're putting these
discrete signals in
one after the other.
We're passing them through
this, which is a digital
filter now.
So what comes out here V prime
is just a convolution of u and
G. We then add the
noise to it.
I claim that what we ought
to do is use the matched
filter here to u.
And if I use a matched filter
to u here, that matched
filter, if I'm using a
pseudonoise sequence, is going
to bingo give me the filter that
I started out with, plus
some noise.
OK why is that?
The property that pseudonoise
sequences have, if I choose
each of the inputs to have the
magnitude of a, and think of
it as being real plus or minus
a, which is what people
usually do.
If you look at the correlation
of this sequence, namely the
correlation of u sub m with the
complex conjugate of u sub
m spaced a little bit, PN
sequences have the property
that this correlation function
looks like an impulse.
OK.
Now how you find sequences that
have that property is
another question.
But in fact they do exist.
There are lots of them.
They're easy to find.
And they have this very
nice property.
Another way to say this is that
is that the vector u has
to be orthogonal to
all of its shifts.
That's exactly what
this is saying.
And another way of saying it
is that u, if you pass it
through the matched filter to
u-- now remember what a
matched filter is on
an analog waveform.
You take a waveform, you switch
it around in time.
You take the complex conjugate
of it, and
that's the matched filter.
And when you convolve u with
this matched filter, what it's
doing is just exactly the same
operation of correlation.
OK in other words, convolution
with one of the sequences
turned around this time, is
the same as correlation.
And most of you have
seen that I'm sure.
So that if we take this matched
filter where u tilde
sub j is equal to the complex
conjugate of u at time minus
j, then I pass u through the
filter G. Forget about the
noise for the time being.
I then pass it through the
matched filter u tilde.
What I'm going to get out, I
claim, is G. And I'll show you
why that is in just a minute.
Let make caution you
about something.
Because you can get very
confused with this picture.
Because as soon as I take this
input, u 1 up to u sub m.
This matched filter is going to
start responding at time u
sub minus m.
And it's going to finish
responding a
time u sub minus 1.
So it responds before
it's hit.
Which again is this business of
thinking of timing at the
receiver being very much delayed
from timing at the
transmitter.
Which is a trick that
we've always played.
Which is why we don't have to
think of filters as being
realizable.
Still in this example, this
becomes confusing.
And I'll show you
why in a minute.
OK so I'm going to assume that
I picked a good PN sequence.
So when I convolve it with its
matched filter I essentially
get an impulse function, namely
a discrete impulse.
Which is the same as saying that
u is orthogonal to all of
its shifts.
And that's exactly what
you what to do.
You want to think of
turning it around
and passing it through.
And that's exactly what
this is doing.
OK so we have the output of
this filter, which is u
convolved with G. We're then
convolving that with this
matched filter u tilde.
And now we use the nice property
of convolution, which
you probably don't think
of very often.
But the nice property that
convolution has, is that it's
both associative and
commutative.
OK.
And therefore when we look at
V prime times u tilde, it's
the convolution of u with G--
that's what the prime is-- all
convolved with the
matched filter u.
Because of the associativity and
the commutativity, you can
reverse these two things so
you're taking the convolution
of u with its matched filter.
When you take the convolution of
u with its matched filter,
you get a delta function.
And you take a delta function
and pass it through G. And
what comes out is a delta
function weighted by a-squared
n, which is just the energy
of what we're putting in.
OK so that says that if we can
find pseudonoise sequences,
all of this works.
And it works just dandy.
If you put noise in,
what happens there?
Well let's analyze the
noise separately.
The noise is going through
this matched filter.
Well if u is a pseudonoise
sequence, if it has this nice
correlation property and you
flip it around in time, it's
going to have the same nice
correlation property.
So that in fact u tilde is
going to have the same
property that it's orthogonal
to all of its time shifts.
If you now look at what happens
when you take Z and
send it through this filter,
and you find the covariance
matrix for Z passed through
this filter, what that
independence gives you is the
correlation function is just
all diagonal, all terms,
all the same.
Which says that all of these
terms and this vector here are
all white Gaussian
noise variables.
So what comes out is the filter
plus white noise.
Which is the same thing that
happened when we put in a
single input with zeros
on both sides.
OK.
So using a PN sequence works
in exactly the same way as
this very special pseudonoise
sequence, which just has one
input in it.
Which happens to be a
pseudonoise sequence
in this term also.
OK so the output then, is
going to be a maximum
likelihood estimate of G. OK,
this is the way that people
typically measure channels.
They use pseudonoise inputs.
And the output that comes
out, namely the
output that comes out.
When we put in a finite duration
pseudonoise sequence,
what we're going to look for
is the output at the exact
instant of the last digit
as the input goes in.
And the output then is G sub
0, followed by G sub 1,
followed by G sub 2,
and then silence.
So you see nothing coming out
until this big burst of
energy, which is all
digits of G.
OK so now we want to put all
of this together into
something called a
rake receiver.
I wish I could spend more time
on the rake receiver because
it's a really neat thing.
It was developed in the 50s
about the same time that
information theory was
getting developed.
But it was developed by people
who were trying to do radar.
And at the same time trying to
do a little communication
along with the radar.
And this was one of the things
they came up with.
So they wanted to measure the
channel and make decisions in
transmitting data both
at the same time.
And the trick here is about the
same as the trick we use
in trying to measure carrier
frequency, and make decisions
at the same time.
Namely you use the decisions
you make
to measure the frequency.
You use the frequency
that you've measured
to make future decisions.
And here, we're going to do
exactly the same thing.
We make decisions.
We use those decisions as a way
of measuring the channel.
We then use the measurements of
the channel to create this
matched filter G tilde.
And that's what we're going to
use to make the decisions.
OK if you have two different
inputs, I mean here we'll just
look at binary inputs.
You take u sub 0 and u sub 1,
and you look at what happens
when you have those
two inputs.
This is just a vector white
Gaussian noise problem that we
looked at in quite a bit of
detail when we were studying
decision theory.
What we want to do is to look
at, I mean if these two
signals are not antipodal to
each other you want to look at
the mean of them.
And you'll want to look at u sub
0 minus that mean, and u
sub 1 minus that mean as
two antipodal signals.
When you go through all of
that, you find that the
maximum likelihood decision is
to take the real part of the
output, of the inner product
of the output, with u sub 0
convolved with g, and the real
part of v convolved with u sub
1 convolved with G.
OK in other words, what's
happening here is that as far
as anybody is concerned, we're
not using u sub 0 and u sub 1
in this making a decision.
We know what the channel is.
And therefore what exists right
before the white noise
is added, is these two signals u
sub 0 convolved with g and u
sub 1 convolved with g.
So we're doing binary
detection on
those two known signals.
And we're using the output to
try to make the best choice
between them.
So this is the thing
that we do.
So we want to use a filter
matched to u sub 0
convolved with g.
Now how do we build a filter
matched to a convolution of
two things?
Well we convolve
u sub 0 with g.
And then we turn the
thing around.
And then we see that after
turning it around what we've
gotten is the turned around
version of u convolved with
the turned around
version of g.
I mean write it down
and you'll see that
that's what you have.
So what you wind up with is
the following figure.
You either send u sub 0
or you send u sub 1.
This is a way to send
one binary digit.
We're sending it by using these
long PN sequences now.
If u sub 0 goes through g, we
got a V prime out, which is
the output before
noise is added.
We then add noise so we get.
And then we pass to try
to detect whether
this or this is true.
We take this output V. We
convolve it with u sub 1
convolved with g, and with
u sub 0 convolved with g.
Now you'll all say I'm
wasting stuff here.
Because I could just put the g
over here and then follow it
with u sub 1 or u sub 0.
Be patient for a little bit.
I want to put both of them in.
And I want to put them
in this order.
And then I make a
decision here.
OK well here comes the clincher
to the argument.
Look at what happens
right there.
If I forget about this and I
forget about this, what I get
here is u sub 0 coming in.
It's going through
the filter g.
It has white noise
added to it.
It goes through the matched
filter to u sub 0.
And what comes out is
a measurement of g.
That's what we showed before.
When we were trying to measure
g, that was the way we did it.
We started out with
a PN sequence, go
through g, add noise--
we can't avoid the noise-- go
through the matched filter.
That is a measurement of
g at that point there.
And if we send u sub 1, that's
a measurement of g at that
point there.
So finally we have the rake
receiver which does both of
these things it once.
You either send u sub
0 or u sub 1.
You go through this filter.
You add white noise.
As far as making a decision is
concerned, you do what we
talked about before.
You compare this output
with this
output to make a decision.
After you make a decision you
go forward in time, because
we've done everything backwards
in time here.
And you take what is going to
come out of here, which hasn't
come out yet.
And you use that to make
a new estimate of g.
You use that estimate of g
turned around in time, to
alter your estimate of the
matched filter to g.
And if you read the notes, the
notes explains what's going on
as far as the timing in
here, a little bit
better than I can here.
But in fact, this is the kind
of circuit that people
actually use to both measure
channels, and to send data at
the same time.
I want stop here because
we're supposed to
evaluate the class.